docteur laurent alexandre bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors cette étude 1 menée par le chu
d'angers
c'est une façon de clore définitivement
le débat sur l'hydrologie chloroquine il
devenait évident qu'une telle étude soit
menée
oui maintenant il faut réaliser des
études aux standards internationaux
nous ne pouvons plus faire des études
bâclé avec des méthodes statistiques qui
ne sont pas acceptables donc l'étude
danger comme l'étude discovery sont des
études qui vont permettre de trancher la
question de la chloroquine nous allons
enfin pouvoir déterminer si la
chloroquine aggrave les malades les
améliore ou n'a pas d'efficacité selon
vous à quel moment on pourra avoir des
résultats fiables de cette étude on va
avoir des résultats intermédiaires mais
ce ne seront pas des résultats
définitifs
normalement discovery et puis l'étude
d'angers vont commencer à donner des
résultats entre quinze jours et trois
semaines
ce seront des résultats intermédiaires
qui n'auront pas une validité
statistiques absolue mais qui donneront
des indications il va falloir attendre
plus de temps pour avoir une certitude
statistique
sauf si l'effet de la chloroquine était
exceptionnel auquel cas on pourrait voir
relativement rapidement les faits lors
de cet essai clinique sur un nombre
important de malades 1300 quand même
même si c'est un peu moins que les 7
discovery alors cette hypothèse de
laclos routine c'est le professeur raoul
vincke et a commencé à en parler il est
pour vous le connaissiez bien vous
l'avenir yémen mais aujourd'hui plus du
tout pourquoi moi je suis un grand fan
un grand admirateur de didier raoul t je
suis profondément déçu je me sens trahi
par la mauvaise qualité des études qui
la sail à hystériser le débat quand je
vois la différence entre la belgique jeu
via bruxelles et la france l'hystérie
autour de la chloroquine et du
traitement de cette maladie en france
alors qu'en belgique nous avons l'union
nationale et où tout le monde est
d'accord sur la stratégie qu'à mieux au
point le gouvernement belge
je suis affolé on est quasiment dans une
guerre civile
médicale en france et y dit raul tu as
contribué à ça en donnant des faux
espoirs et en faisant croire que il
avait tranché la question
ce qui n'est pas le cas parce qu'ici la
chloroquine donnait des résultats
éblouissant ça se verrait une très large
partie des new yorkais prennent de la
chloroquine et comme vous avez pu le
constater il y à un ballet ininterrompu
de cercueil qui sortent des hôpitaux new
yorkais donc il n'ya pas de médicaments
miracles
bill gates lui-même a incité à la
prudence et à continuer les recherches
il n'y aura en réalité pas de traitement
miracle il n'y aura pas de traitements
rapidement il va falloir des mois et des
mois et des mois de recherches
scientifiques très rigoureuse et
complexe pour arriver à trouver des
thérapeutiques donc aujourd'hui il faut
faire attention à ne pas donner de faux
espoirs
parce que la réaction des français
pourrait être terrible
s'ils sont demain déçu donc il faut être
prudent attendre le résultat de l'étude
discovery et de la belle étude qui est
en train d'être réalisés selon les
standards scientifiques internationaux
au chu d'angers
et en attendant il faut faire attention
à ne pas raconter n'importe quoi la
science ne se fait pas sur les plateaux
de télévision
elle se fait avec des méthodes
statistiques des méthodes scientifiques
irréprochable ce qui n'est pas le cas
hélas jusqu'à maintenant mais c'est en
train de changer avec l'étude discovery
et l'étude du chu d'angers
dans la situation d'urgence dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons dans la
situation de guerre 1 pour reprendre les
mots du président bien certains disent
on n'a pas le temps de respecter le
protocole habituel
alors pourquoi pas finalement ne pas se
baser sur le travail du professeur out à
grande échelle qu'est ce que vous
répondez oui mais eux vous commettez une
erreur on fait l'hypothèse que soit la
chloroquine est il efficace soit-elle
est efficace mais il ya une troisième
possibilité c'est qu'elle aggrave les
malades parce qu'on sait très bien que
la toro kid a parfois des effets
paradoxaux
c'est à dire qu'elle n'agit pas de la
même façon en éprouvettes et chez les
malades
si on prend le chikungunya est bien la
chloroquine tu le virus quand il est en
éprouvette en revanche elle aggrave
l'état des malades
il ne faudrait pas qu'il se passe la
même chose avec
que le virus du coc vite 19 il ne
faudrait pas qu'on a une efficacité en
éprouvette mais qu'en fait les malades
et un taux de mortalité supérieure avec
la chloroquine que sans chloroquine
comme 98 % des malades guérissent
spontanément il faut faire attention à
ne pas passer à 97 ou 96% dans
l'hypothèse où la chloroquine aggravait
l'état des patients
or l'état actuel des études ne permet
pas d'éliminer cette hypothèse il est
possible que la chloroquine et un petit
effet il est possible qu'elle n'ait pas
d'effets et il est possible qu'elle ait
un effet négatif
nous devons donc être prudent parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de preuve de
l'efficacité de la chloroquine s'il y
avait une preuve de l'efficacité de la
chloroquine je peux vous dire que je
conseillerai immédiatement qu'on la
donne à tout le monde mais ça n'est pas
le cas nous avons déjà vu des
médicaments contre des virus qui
augmentait la mortalité des malades par
rapport à l'absence de traitement donc
soyons prudents on peut en donner en
compassionnel aux malades mais en
faisant attention et il faut cesser de
faire croire que ces traitements miracle
il faut cesser de faire croire que c'est
un traitement qui marche dans 100% des
cas nous devons maintenant être très
humble très modeste nous nous sommes
tous trompés sur la dynamique de cette
de cette épidémie personnellement en
janvier gelé complètement sous-estimé
je me suis vautré comme tout le monde
comme d'ailleurs didier à holt
souvenez vous il y a encore la vidéo sur
youtube disponibles didier raoul tous
disaient que le coronavirus faisaient
moins de morts que la trottinette
donc nous nous sommes tous trompés il
faut maintenant faire attention il faut
respecter les protocoles selon les les
les méthodes scientifiques
internationaux reconnus il faut pas
donner de faux espoirs
il faut être prudent c'est un combat qui
va être très très long donc il faut que
les français ne soient pas déçus par les
faux espoirs et comprennent que la
science va avancer doucement parce que
ya pas de solution magique trouver un
remède contre ce virus va prendre
probablement beaucoup de temps je pense
qu'il y à moins d'une chance sur cent
qu'on ait un traitement vraiment
efficace avant les vacances d'été et je
le regrette
je ne dis pas ça de gaieté de coeur
c'est une constatation
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de bons résultats
avec les médicaments anti hezbollah dans
les résultats préliminaires les épines
sur la chloroquine en chine sont pas du
tout démonstrative
donc il va falloir hélas cette passion
merci beaucoup docteur alexandre je
rappelle que vous êtes entrepreneur et
essayiste et on envie